[Music]
you want to get back on the court and
ask your agent I want to get you there
but we are in a lockout there are no
actual games - why you think these fools
these rich white dudes gonna let these
sexy sport fall by the wayside it steams
my family I need us to be one big family
again football is fun but it don't sell
sneakers the move merge and inspire rap
lyrics they need your services the NBA
won control of a game that we play we
played better they invented a game on
top of a game that I see a whole
infrastructure they put the control back
in the hands and I was behind the ball
what you gonna do but I'm not full up a
chair
we're at the height of the information
error we need a story what are you doing
there this is my career you have a
chance start to do what has never been
done before
well me given the rap I wonder that this
is the match of everyone's been dying to
see song video thinking of breaking up
or happy marriage what you saw yesterday
this was just the beginning of what
could be whole new industry
is episode you did all that you normally
would have blab oh he's scared
we don't need to leave we are disruptive
is your game now
you were born for way more than this no
that'll fool you
[Applause]
[Music]